trip Adventures is making a pit stop in
Las Vegas this weekend at the Thomas
Mack and right now we are joined by
Taylor Burrell she's a Disney on Ice
performer Welcome to our show thank you
thank you for having me I'm so excited
to have you here tell us about your show
what can we expect this weekend yes so
Disney on Ice presents road trip
Adventures is actually Disney on Ice's
most interactive show ever so that's
what makes it a favorite for a lot of
our guests because they get to see their
kids have fun and smile in a very brand
new way there are so many characters
there this weekend uh what is your role
with the Disney on Ice so I am a host
with Disney on Ice so you will see me in
the audience dancing singing along
high-fiving you
I have one of the best jobs because I
get to interact with our guests we're
looking right now at some of the footage
here name some of the characters that
the kids and the families are going to
see this weekend get froze in there they
see Mary Poppins flying around there yes
you did that is definitely a favorite
with the parents
we have the incredible
Mickey Donald Goofy and it's really a
good time you can it is so much joy when
you go to Disney On Ice it's so much fun
is there a character experience that's
taking place as well there is so
actually an hour prior to each show we
have way finding with Moana okay and it
is an additional ticket you can purchase
online and it's amazing we have a
character or two that may stop by and
you take pictures and stuff with the
characters 100 yeah how long have you
been involved with Disney on Ice well I
have been with Disney on Ice since 2019
so we took a break during the pandemic
and then now we're back in full effects
so what's it like for you being there in
their crowd you're seeing the kids and
the families what's that like for you to
see the excitement on everyone's face I
love it yeah my favorite part is about
the storytelling I sing the guest
interact and the kids when Elsa comes
out there's always one child out there
that just screams at the top of their
lungs and so it's really beautiful
beautiful to see well Taylor thank you
so much for joining us this is a tree
thank you for joining us have fun this
weekend so Disney on Ice presents road
trip Adventures over at the Thomas and
Mac there are shows happening all
weekend through Sunday for tickets go to
unlvtickets.com or call
702-739 fans